"El colorante para alimentos azul se
puede oxidar con blanqueador doméstico,
que contiene iones OCI¯ -u O, C, I menos- para
formar productos incoloros, como se representa
en la ecuación anterior." Tenemos esta ecuación,
donde tenemos colorante para alimentos azul,
que tiene esta fórmula química, y está
reaccionando con blanqueador o hipoclorito,
y está haciendo productos incoloros, de modo que
obtenemos este cambio de color de azul a incoloro.
"Un estudiante usó un espectrofotómetro ajustado
a una longitud de onda de 625 nanómetros para
estudiar la absorbancia del colorante alimentario
con el tiempo durante el proceso de blanqueo.
En el estudio, el blanqueador está presente en
exceso", y subrayaré eso porque es importante,
"está presente en exceso, de modo que la
concentración de hipoclorito sea esencialmente
constante a lo largo de la reacción. El
estudiante utilizó datos del estudio para
generar las gráficas que están a continuación."
Así que nos gustaría responder al inciso a:
"Con base en las gráficas anteriores, ¿cuál es
el orden de la reacción con respecto al colorante
para alimentos azul?" Entonces tenemos mucha
información aquí, tenemos estas tres gráficas.
Si escribimos la absorbancia como A, estamos
buscando la concentración de A con el tiempo,
estamos buscando el logaritmo natural de A con el
tiempo y también, por último, estamos buscando 1
sobre la concentración de A con el tiempo. Así
que nos gustaría saber cuál es el orden de la
reacción con respecto a nuestro azul. Mi primer
instinto, cuando veo este problema, en realidad
es un poco de pánico, porque tenemos mucha
información aquí, entonces ¿cómo lo abordamos?
También tenemos un poco más de información para
este problema. Tenemos la hoja de ecuaciones,
esta es la parte de la hoja de ecuaciones que es
relevante para este problema. Estas son todas las
ecuaciones que tienen que ver con la cinética que
se refieren a las velocidades de reacción, de modo
que eso es lo que estamos viendo aquí. Entonces
tenemos tres cosas posibles que podrían ser
útiles para este problema, o quizás no, ¿cierto?
Tenemos esta primera ecuación que nos da la ley de
velocidad integrada de primer orden, tenemos la
segunda ecuación que nos da la ley de velocidad
integrada de segundo orden y tenemos esta tercera
ecuación que en realidad es una ecuación para la
vida media. Entonces, nos dicen que la vida media
es de 0.693 dividido entre K, y esa es la vida
media para una reacción de primer orden. Aquí es
importante recordar, y lo volveremos a ver en un
segundo, que esto es una constante debido a que
K es una constante. Entonces, nuestra vida media
es también una constante para una reacción de
primer orden. Esta es la información que tenemos,
echemos un vistazo en estas gráficas. Comenzaremos
revisando sólo la primera gráfica. Resulta que
podemos obtener mucha información con sólo mirar
la concentración de A a lo largo del tiempo. De
modo que si vemos esta primera gráfica y vemos
la concentración de nuestros productos azules
que disminuye con el tiempo, podemos ver de
inmediato que esto no es lineal, así que el
hecho de que no sea lineal inmediatamente nos
dice que no es de orden 0. Si fuera de orden 0,
esperaríamos ver una línea recta que dibujaré en
rosa con una línea punteada porque eso no es en
realidad lo que estamos viendo. Entonces no es de
orden 0. También podemos obtener más información
mirando esta gráfica. Sabemos que no es de orden
0. Podemos decir si esta primera gráfica es de
primer orden y la respuesta es: en realidad sí
podemos. Si recuerdas la hoja de ecuaciones,
dijimos que en las reacciones de primer orden la
vida media es constante. Y yo diría que esta es
quizás una de las cosas más importantes sobre
las reacciones de primer orden. Eso significa
que el tiempo que toma que la concentración
baje a la mitad de lo que era es el mismo,
no importa cuál era la concentración inicial,
no importa en qué punto de la reacción está,
eso es algo que podemos obtener sólo mirando esta
primera gráfica. Podemos ver cuánto tiempo toma
llegar a la mitad de la concentración y ver si
eso es algo que cambia con el tiempo así que, por
ejemplo, si comenzamos con 0.8 aquí, la mitad de
0.8 es 0.4. Así que podemos ver cuánto tiempo toma
ir de 0.8 a 0.4, que está justo aquí. Si vamos
abajo, podemos ver que tarda 20 segundos tener la
concentración de 0.4 a partir de 0.8 unidades de
absorbancia. Podemos, ahora, ver que la vida media
para pasar de 0.4 a 0.2 toma otros 20 segundos, y
así podemos hacer esto una y otra vez. Podríamos
pasar de 0.2 a 0.1 y observaríamos la continuación
de un patrón. Podemos ver que siempre toma 20
segundos reducir la concentración a la mitad.
Y así, con base en la gráfica 1, inmediatamente
sabemos que nuestra reacción es de primer
orden, porque nuestra vida media es constante,
ni siquiera tenemos que mirar las otras gráficas.
Hay otra forma de resolver este problema,
quizás lo recuerdes con base en las ecuaciones
que tenemos o con base en ecuaciones que conoces.
Entonces, una razón que conocemos y por la que
podríamos decir que esta reacción es de primer
orden es porque t½ es constante. La otra razón por
la que sabemos que esta es de primer orden es que,
cuando una reacción es de primer orden en el
reactante, graficar el logaritmo natural de
la reacción contra tiempo da una línea recta; y
podemos ver en la gráfica 2 que este es el caso.
Así que tenemos estas dos piezas de evidencia, la
gráfica 1 y la gráfica 2, que nos dicen que esta
reacción particular en realidad es de primer orden
con respecto al colorante para alimentos azul.